crowds gathered across the united states
over the weekend for more protests in
the wake of george floyd's killing in
police custody
two weeks ago thousands flocked to the
heart of washington d.c to voice their
opposition to racism
and police brutality it comes as the
majority
of minneapolis city council members
pledged to dismantle the police
department
whose former officers have been charged
for their role
in floyd's death
earlier we spoke with dw correspondent
stephan simons in washington
we asked him about the momentum of this
protest movement
and what it means for november's
presidential vote
that means that the sitting president is
in more trouble regarding his
re-election bid
latest polls suggest that the democratic
presidential candidate
joe biden is leading with a widening gap
before
president donald trump even in those
iffy states where
donald trump surprised everybody in 2016
and took the states and
won the votes and the president seems to
be keenly aware of this now the
democratic party would probably
try and hone in on what the
african-american
community but others two experts and
observers too call now
became a movement and call now a
movement
so this is going to be interesting what
the impact will be that it will have an
impact
is absolutely clear and that was the
view from washington from dw stefan
simons
meanwhile elsewhere in the world britain
was among the many countries that saw
weekend anti-racism protest over
the death of george floyd while in u.s
police custody
while the rallies were mostly peaceful
scuffles broke out between protesters
and police in london
demonstrators also vandalized statues
including one
honoring a slave trader
[Applause]
an act of vandalism or an historic
moment
for years this statue of a 17th century
british slave trader in the southwestern
english city of bristol was
controversial
as the global anti-racism protests
reached the city on sunday
anger found event in the 125 year old
bronze figure of edward colston
that statue represents years of
oppression it represents years of hurt
and just a lot of emotion that and
hatred that has been built up inside of
us that we've internalized for years
and that coming down today hopefully
signifies change
in central london clashes broke out
between police and black lives matter's
demonstrators
statue of former british prime minister
winston churchill was also vandalized
the scuffles came towards the end of
what had been mostly peaceful protests
drawing tens of thousands to their
capital
rallying to condemn police brutality
after the death of black man george
floyd while in police custody in the u.s
the british government condemned the
violence as well as protests going ahead
despite the coronavirus pandemic
we know we respect the right to protest
but we do not
respect and it is completely unlawful to
participate in acts of disorder
vandalism
violence and assault we are in the midst
of a health pandemic right now
and under the rules that we have put in
place it is illegal
for gatherings of six or more people
outside in open air to get together and
that is unacceptable
for these protesters at least there's
more than one global pandemic
on our hands but in reality
and i am joined now by our political
correspondent emmanuella chase who
attended a protest
yesterday in the german capital here in
berlin so tell us a little bit more
about the turnout
yes on saturday around 15 000 people
gathered here in berlin and of course
even interior i mean
um sorry a house minister yen span was
very worried he voiced concerns because
this protest
happens um in in the middle of a
pandemic but to be fair i was in the
middle of that crowd and even if social
distancing wasn't
respected people uh the majority of
people
were wearing masks so that was uh quite
uh responsible it was a responsible
process also people were there to show
their support to the us
protesters and it was a very moving
experience to see so many people
gathered there especially at the moment
they knelt
for the time of george floyd's agony
8 minutes 46 seconds so of course
many very many worries about the fact
that the protest took place during a
pandemic but also a responsible
protest and it wasn't just about
systemic racism
in the united states was it no it was
also very much about systemic racism
here in europe and in particular here in
germany and also people gathered
he wanted to denounce police violence
that also happened
here there were many signs for example
showing the name
of asylum seeker uri jallo who died
in police custody here in germany in
2005. so it was very much about
racism not only in the us but also
racism that is experienced here by the
black community
how is the german government tackling it
well last last week on thursday the
berlin senate passed a law an
anti-discrimination law so that's the
first step to try and end for example
racial profiling by police in public
institutions for example and in 2006 on
a federal level so
nationwide there was a law that was
passed to try and end systemic
racism in employment for example or
between private individuals
emanuela chase in berlin thank you